sher fermions in North Carolina
hey Jeremy how are you hi Dave great to
talk to you
you too man what's up well I'm recently
married within the last couple of weeks
and I'm also a newly married to your
podcast it's been it's been really
awesome to listen to and I think it's
finally pushed me to the point to where
I'm I'm ready to be one of those that's
not the 70% living paycheck-to-paycheck
good my question is I said something to
my wife the other night about you know
getting into the FPU and and you know
combining our finances and everything
and and I understand her hesitancy
because you know I told her about my
past with being reckless with money and
spending spending everybody else's money
and everything and and I I understand
that you know she's concerned but how do
you how can how can we combine our
finances and is there anything that I
can do to ease her anxiety and that
because you know I'm ready to I want to
do this right too late she married you
if she was that dad-blame concerned
about you being a complete in there too
well who doesn't take care of life and
is irresponsible she probably shouldn't
walk the aisle yeah so I'm willing to
marry you and put my entire future at
risk by your misbehavior and your
irresponsibility but god forbid we
shared a checkbook that's not logical oh
I agree okay so let's just keep talking
it through and say honey the number one
calls a divorce in North America today's
money fights and money problems and the
number one point of discord in almost
every marriage is money
I don't want ours to be that way I love
you too much for us to live a life that
way let's go through this class together
so that we can get on this
Paige and if we don't want to do it
we'll decide that together but we need
to go through and get the information
and have these discussions and learn to
put ourselves on the same page we want
to combine our finances initially let's
just get in this class together and go
can use that he's willing together Oh
God then it'll take care of himself
you go through Financial Peace
University for nine weeks if you go
through Financial Peace University for
nine weeks with your spouse and you
don't combine your finances your brain
doesn't work well I will I will I will
completely I will completely convince
both of you by then yeah we're we're
just saving up to actually buy the
membership thing right now I'm thinking
probably within the next month how much
do you make up here I only make about
thirty and she makes about twenty she
went fifteen thousand dollars a year and
a hundred bucks you can't find well you
wanna save up for a hundred bucks to
fill up their trailer
thank you I was in a house you should do
what now I said we're we're in the
middle of like setting up our house
right now because we both started with
nothing essentially okay that's fine but
yeah you desperately need to go through
the class if you don't have a hundred
bucks I mean that's a bad thing so hold
on we'll pay for it as your gift to your
wedding gift but both of you have to
attend and someday when you're rich and
famous because you learned all this
stuff you have to pay for ten people to
go and that's the result of me giving it
to you for free once that's my rule